und hallo und herzlich willkommen tsum
heute plus live stream unserer corona
sprechstunde am dienstag den 31
märz 2020 ja die fragen sind immer noch
da wie lange wird es dauern brauchen wir
eine massen pflicht wir möchten die
sache mit euch besprechen wir wollen
eure fragen mit aufnehmen in diesen
stream vip sprechen heute mit dem
biologen jonas schmidt-chanasit vom
bernhard-nocht-institut für
tropenmedizin in hamburg er ist
spezialisiert auf ihren die vom tier auf
den menschen übergehen so ganz grob
gesagt aber natürlich seit wochen auch
mit dem neuen corona virus beschäftigt
und deswegen ein sehr gefragter
gesprächspartner deswegen fangen wir
gleich an
herr schmidt chanasit hören sie mich
sind sie da ja ich kann sehr gut hören
schönen guten abend wundervoll alle
sehen sich derzeit nach positiven
nachrichten dass wir irgendwie ein
hoffnungsschimmer bekommen jetzt gab es
heute neue zahlen vom
robert-koch-institut können sie da
irgendwie eine positive entwicklung für
uns daraus ableiten
ja es ist erst einmal positiv dass die
zahlen nicht dramatisch weiter gestiegen
ist ob das jetzt wirklich schon eine
trendumkehr ist bei der zahl der
neuinfektionen bleibt abzuwarten eine
weitere positive nachricht die man
sicherlich auch mitteilen kann ist dass
nach wie vor die kapazitäten auf den
intensivstationen ausreichend sind wir
haben in großen teilen deutschlands
keine überlastung nur wenige regionen wo
das grenzwertig ist das sind doch schon
positive nachrichten wir müssen jetzt
natürlich noch weiter abwarten was ich
in den nächsten tagen dort tut und wenn
sich das weiter so bestätigen sollte
kann man sicherlich dann nach ostern
darüber nachdenken welche maßnahmen man
dann lockern kann für alle die erst noch
nicht genau wissen wie eigentlich die
aktuellen zahlen aussehen fassen wir das
mal ganz kurz zusammen das hat mein
kollege christian rufus für uns gemacht
die zahl der menschen die in deutschland
mit corona infiziert sind steigt weiter
und so auch die kurve nach den zahlen
der johns hopkins universität die ihre
ergebnisse von instituten aber auch
regionalen medien bezieht im schnitt
verdoppeln sich diese bestätigten corona
fälle momentan alle 5,9 tage eine
leichte verbesserung zu gestern da waren
es noch 5,5 tage
die bundesregierung strebt an dass ich
bald nur noch alle zehn tage die
fallzahlen verdoppeln und die kurve
nicht mehr so stark steigt amtliche
zahlen von den gesundheitsämtern kommen
vom robert koch institut
danach gibt es 61 1913 bestätigte corona
fälle in deutschland
wobei da auch die zahl der menschen mit
drin steckt die schon genesen sind
16.100 von ihnen haben die infektion
also überstanden an cholera gestorben
sind bisher 583 menschen 128 mehr als
gestern noch das sind die zahlen von
heute morgen 8 uhr 15
die sterblichkeitsrate liegt laut robert
koch institut im moment bei einem
knappen prozent in deutschland immer
noch deutlich unter dem europäischen und
weltweiten durchschnitt den grund dafür
sehen wir darin dass für früh getestet
haben dass wir viel testen
dass wir ja eben auch viele leichte
fälle in unserer testung haben und
dadurch ist die sterberate aktuell
liegen aber auch wieder mal ein hinweis
die meldungen die wir haben haben wir
ein zeitverzug
und natürlich werden menschen zuerst
infiziert gemeldet und die menschen
sterben ja dann erst später nach einem
gewissen krankheitsverlauf ich gehe also
davon aus nach wie vor dass die
sterberaten steigen werden
ja also zahlen die uns noch nicht so
richtig beruhigen darüber sprechen wir
heute mit dem theologen professor jonas
schmidt-chanasit vom
bernhard-nocht-institut für
tropenmedizin
eine frage die uns mich also nehme ich
schon erreicht habe kam von an belly auf
instagram warum steigen die zahlen der
infizierten weiter obwohl wir gerade ein
kontaktverbot haben
na gut also diese maßnahmen mit dieser
sehr strikten maßnahmen die ergriffen
wurden sind noch nicht so lange in kraft
dass wir hier schon die deutliche
effekte sehen würden
und immer so um 14 tage warten bis wir
dort ein effekt sehen es deutet sich
schon etwas an wir müssen ja aber sehr
vorsichtig sein und noch genießen tage
abwarten ob sich das denn bestätigt
diese trendumkehr und dann wissen wir ob
diese sehr starken maßnahmen ergriffen
wurden auch wirksam sind und wie stark
sie eben wirksam sind wenn wir bei den
themenkomplex dieses kurvenverlauf das
mal bleiben dann erreichen uns fragen
die sich nicht mit dem kurvenverlauf in
deutschland beschäftigen sondern mit dem
in china der ja doch sehr auffällig
abgeflachten ist auf einmal und da wird
von verschiedenen usern gefragt am
alfred kuhn und von shiraz mai zoom auf
youtube ob die zahlen verlässlich sind
oder nicht doch ein bisschen fragwürdig
na gut wir müssen zu china sagen dass
wir hier immer trennen müssen buchen
region bay und der rest von china china
ist eben nicht china sondern die über 90
prozent der infektionen die dort
registriert wurden kommen aus kuba
das heißt der rest von china ist nach
wie vor sehr sehr sehr empfänglich für
eine infektion und es kann jederzeit
dazu kommen dass der ausbruch wieder
beginnt und die fallzahlen steigen
das ist die situation die zweite
situation der große unterschied zu
deutschland ist dass die maßnahme
natürlich dramatisch stärker waren china
also wesentlich strikter als wir uns das
hier jemals vorstellen könnten
und dazu geführt haben dass es wirklich
ein jahr fast 100 prozentigen rückgang
gegeben hat das ist schon so und wir
werden jetzt sehen wenn diese maßnahmen
gelockert werden und das ist momentan
der fall wie die fallzahlen dann auch
wieder nach oben gehen werden
damit ist zu rechnen wie gesagt in china
ist das keinesfalls der stand dass
epidemie vorbei wäre sie ist gestoppt
worden und es kann jederzeit wieder dazu
kommen dass es zu weiteren ausbrüchen
kommt und dann müssen auch wieder in
china entsprechende gegenmaßnahmen
getroffen werden aber vertrauen sie den
offiziellen zahlen der behörden dort das
ist ja doch keine demokratie sondern mit
natur bis autokratie gut wir können
jetzt nur mit den zahlen rechnen die uns
natürlich erreichen ob das jetzt der
realität entspricht ich wage das
natürlich zum teil auch
zu bezweifeln das ist wirklich neu
infektionen gegeben hat aber das hängt
ja auch damit zusammen wie viel und die
breit getestet wird wenn eben bestimmten
regionen nicht getestet wird dann hat
man eben auch 0 infektion auch wenn sie
natürlich tatsächlich stattfinden
davon ist auszugehen ich habe mal unser
gespräch in die verschiedenen
themenblöcke gegliedert einmal den
kurvenverlauf da haben wir jetzt müssen
wir geredet viele menschen sorgen sich
um ansteckungen und das führt uns dann
später auch zur frage mit den massen
also wenn ihr fragen hat professor
schmidt chanasit bitte in die kommentare
packen wir versuchen sie mit aufzunehmen
aber es sind immer noch sehr sehr viele
niki könig hat auf instagram gefragt
kann ich schon in der inkubationszeit
jemanden anstecken da scheint es immer
noch große fragezeichen zu geben wann
ich eigentlich ein virus weitergeben
kann
ja das ist möglich wir sagen pre
symptomatisch also bevor man eine
symptomatik entwickelt bevor man husten
fieber kammern andere menschen anstecken
diese information oder diese
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis ist aber
auch relativ neu die haben wir erst in
den letzten wochen geworden dass schon
ein ja nicht unerheblicher teil der
infektionen von diesem präsente ma
tischen oder asymptomatischen patienten
aus geht insofern ist das schon ein
wichtiger faktor der zu weiteren
infektionen führen kann und der eben zu
berücksichtigen ist gerade eben in den
modellen wie man sozusagen jetzt gerade
die man berechnet und wo man ihm
erfahren will wie es mit ihnen
weitergeht das heißt dann müssen wir
weiterhin vorsichtig sein
deswegen wollen viele menschen wissen wo
sie sich anstecken können bzw wo sie das
virus weitergeben können ich nehme mal
fabian auf instagram auch der hat
gefragt wie lange überleben die viren
auf edelstahl da gibt es ja
widersprüchliche angaben gibt es
mittlerweile gesicherte erkenntnisse
dass es immer noch ein fragezeichen
in der widersprüchliche angaben würde
ich nicht sagen die informationen sind
sehr begrenzt es gibt natürlich
laborexperiment die das untersucht haben
die da sozusagen zeitraum zum teil von
mehreren tagen auch festgestellt haben
aber man muss ganz klar sagen dass das
ist natürlich unter laborbedingungen in
der realität sieht das ganz anders aus
dort spielen gerade die umwelteinflüsse
eine entscheidende rolle das heißt
sonneneinstrahlung
feuchtigkeit temperatur und oder diesen
sage ich mal umweltbedingungen ist es
eher wahrscheinlich dass das nicht
mehrere tage sind sondern wenige minuten
bis einiger stunden es kommt auch ganz
entscheidend darauf an wie die virus
menge ist die auf edelstahl denn zum
beispiel aufgebracht wird und in welcher
flüssigkeit summieren sich befinden
insofern sollte man diese
schmierinfektion die möglich sind man
kann sie nicht ausschließen aber auch
nicht überbewerten man muss sozusagen
sich immer auf den haus übertragungsweg
fokussieren das ist ganz wichtig und das
ist nach wie vor die tröpfcheninfektion
da es heißt der enge kontakt mit
menschen über einen gewissen zeitraum
das darf man nicht aus dem blick
verlieren sonst lenkt man sich eher mit
unwichtigen sachen ab konzentriert sich
auf die falschen sachen und vergisst das
eigentliche was wichtig ist um die
infektion zu vermeiden
trotzdem erreichen uns diese fragen
weiterhin auch ganz konkret wie
wahrscheinlich ist es sich über einen
kugelschreiber wie ich ihn gerade in der
hand halbe zu anzustecken also ich sag
mal wenn ich jetzt infiziert wäre in die
hand husten was ich nicht machen soll
den kugelschreiber anfasse ihnen liegen
lassen und dann kommt eine halbe stunde
später mein kollege räumt hinter mir auf
was ja auch nicht zu uns heute ist es
dann tatsächlich noch etwas wo man sagen
muss das ist ein infizierter gegenstand
also sie sehen schon an ihrer
schilderung dass das sehr theoretisch
ist also wie viel da zusammenkommen erst
zusammen kann muss erst mal müssen sie
infektiös sein das heißt eine große
menge von virus durch ihre durch ihren
husten ausscheiden dann direkt den
kugelschreiber anfassen ihnen liegen
lassen dann muss derjenige ebenen
relativen kurzen zeitabstand auch wieder
den kugelschreiber anpassen und sich
danach direkt ins gesicht fassen
sie sehen schon dass das alles andere
als wahrscheinlich ist wenn man
eigentlich die hygiene regeln befolgt
die wir ständig jeden tag mantraartig
wiederholen insofern bitte konzentrieren
sie sich auf die wichtigen sachen die
relevant sind hier besteht eine
theoretische möglichkeit ja das kann man
nicht verneinen aber sie ist theoretisch
und die wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering
es gilt wahrscheinlich dann auch für die
frage von anderem auf youtube wie groß
ist das risiko sich anzustecken wenn
beim bäcker brötchen und geld
abwechselnd mit handschuhen angefasst
werden ja auch dort besteht natürlich
theoretisch die möglichkeit wenn jemand
eben auch den geld
hustet oder sich davor die hand gepostet
hat den geldscheinen denn übergibt und
nicht unmittelbar danach auch wieder den
geldscheinen und mir danach wieder mit
der hand ins gesicht fasse das ist zu
infektionen kommen kann
es ist nicht ausgeschlossen aber bitte
noch mal konzentrieren sie sich darauf
ihren abstand zu anderen menschen zu
halten sich nicht an rufen zu lassen und
wenn sie selber krank sind wie gesagt
sich zu isolieren in der wohnung das
sind schon ganz wichtige maßnahmen und
dann muss man sich über diese anderen ja
letztendlich infektionswege die eine
rolle spielen könnten aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist wesentlich
geringer nicht so viele gedanken machen
das führt uns zu grossen diskussionen um
masken die jetzt doch voll anrollte
österreich hat gestern angekündigt dass
es eine maske pflicht in supermärkten
geben wird ab mittwoch werden dort
masken verteilt mittelfristig sollen die
auch in der öffentlichkeit getragen
werden
die stadt jena führt ab kommenden montag
in allen verkaufsstellen im öffentlichen
nahverkehr und gebäuden mit
publikumsverkehr masken pflicht ein
das fand die landesregierung jetzt nicht
so richtig super und da muss man sich
natürlich fragen was bringt jetzt was
bevor wir darüber sprechen professor
schmidt chanasit werden wir erst mal
eine kleine maz zeigen wir haben nämlich
menschen auf der straße gefragt was sie
von den massen unter masken pflicht
halten
ich finds gut denn wir wollen sie nicht
noch mehr haben es muss langsam was
passieren
die leute müssen umdenken also ich finde
das passiert nicht gut nicht an astor
linie weil man sich das selber schützen
waren vor allem die anderen schützt und
ich denke alles was man unternehmen kann
um andere zu schützen sollte man danach
tun haben sie
wissen sie wieso also es gibt leider
keine zu kaufen obwohl meine schweren
die hat eine nähmaschine ich hoffe dass
die funktioniert also ich bin erstmal
nicht begeistert ich habe schon mal mit
normaler gearbeitet und gelaufen ich
denke mal sicherlich zum schutz ist es
vielleicht ganz gut aber für die älteren
leute ist es eine qual so ein ding oft
zu setzen weil die sowieso schönen alten
mutter kann wie die maske jetzt schon
freiwillig oder die trag ich schon jetzt
14 tage freiwillig weil ich eben die
geschäfte gehe oder unterwegs bin ich
habe auch die handschuhe
ich möchte meine enkelkinder irgendwann
gesund wieder sehen und ein arm nehmen
tja also ein wirkliches streitthema
merken wir da gehen die meinungen und
teilweise sehr auseinander über diesen
großen fragenkomplex was machen wir
jetzt wie geht es weiter
spreche ich gerade mit dem virologen
professor schmidt chanasit vom bernhard
nocht institut für tropenmedizin in
hamburg was ist denn jetzt ihr stand
also das ganze ging jedoch hin und her
zuerst hieß es brauchen wir nicht bringt
nichts jetzt wird es teilweise
eingeführt wozu würden sie tendieren ein
sehr komplexes thema was man jetzt in
einem satz nicht beantworten kann also
erstens wie ist die lage in deutschland
wir haben seit wochen eine diskussion um
fehlende schutzkleidung masken und
atemschutz also mundschutz und
atemschutz in den krankenhäusern
pflegeheimen
dies ist noch nicht gelöst das heißt
warum führen wir jetzt diese diskussion
um eine breite sozusagen masken pflicht
in deutschland wir müssen uns erst mal
um die krankenhäuser um die pflegeheime
kümmern wo die wirklich benötigt werden
wenn dieser zustand irgendwann mal
erreicht ist auch mit dem entsprechenden
sozialen backup dass da wirklich
genügend da für die nächsten monate dann
könnte man das diskutieren und selbst
dann stellt sich die frage ist das
sinnvoll
und da gibt es eine klare aussage auch
der weko dass eine allgemeine masken
pflicht für draußen nicht sinnvoll ist
es gibt keine wissenschaftliche evidenz
dafür
für wen ist dieser modus sinnvoll für
erkrankte ja weil dadurch die tröpfchen
nicht soweit durch die gegend fliegen
und man die anderen schützt also nochmal
ganz klar der mundschutz ist nicht zum
selbstschutz gedacht sondern um andere
zu schützen
und jetzt kommt der dritte punkt warum
diese diskussion aufgekommen ist wir
haben ihnen eben in den letzten wochen
lernen müssen das eben auch
asymptomatische dieses virus übertragen
können und dann kann man sich natürlich
denken dass es rein theoretisch sinnvoll
wäre denn eben auch nicht erkrankte
diese mit diesem mundschutz tragen um
andere zu schützen aber selbst dafür
gibt es keine wissenschaftliche evidenz
ball die haben ja andere maßnahmen
ergriffen um die anderen zu schützen
leben nicht kontakt verboten abstand
halten
das reicht aus dann brauche ich nicht
noch zusätzlich eine maske aber da
könnte man ja sagen
andersrum wir können das kontaktverbot
wieder vielleicht herunterfahren wenn
mehr manchen sich in der öffentlichkeit
schützen
da gibt es ja jetzt noch viele versuche
war sich fast selber zu bauen aus stoff
es gibt anleitungen tatsächlich mit
kaffee filtern online mit küchenpapier
mit klopapier ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist
können wir gleich noch mal besprechen
aber das wäre doch angenommen wir hätten
genug masten für alle deutschen wäre das
doch vielleicht eine maßnahme dass wir
wieder mehr kontakt zueinander haben
können wenn wir an eine maske tragen
nein das lenkt von den wirklichen
problemen ab noch haben wir diesen
zustand nicht und selbst wenn wir diese
masken haben verleitet das natürlich
dass man sich scheinbar auch in
sicherheit welt und die ist nicht da an
diesen massen gibt natürlich rechts und
links die sind ja nicht sozusagen so
fest anliegen wie die richtigen
atemschutzmasken das heißt es besteht
natürlich trotzdem ein risiko wenn ich
engen kontakt habe und mich im
geschlossenen raum mit mehreren leuten
aufhalte es ist ja kein
hundertprozentiger schutz sowohl
natürlich gar nicht für mich als auch
für die anderen das muss jedem klar sein
also insofern ist diese diskussion
meines erachtens jetzt kommt vollkommen
zum falschen zeitpunkt es besteht auch
nicht die notwendigkeit in deutschland
eine breite masken pflicht einzuführen
wir haben noch keine italienischen
zustände die intensivstation sind
größtenteils nicht überlastet haben
kapazität und wir sind eigentlich er
bald an dem punkt dass wir darüber reden
welche maßnahmen gelockert werden und
nicht dass es eine weitere verschärfung
gibt also darum ist diese diskussion
fehlgeleitet und ein anderer punkt ist
nochmal wir müssen ja auch sozusagen
langsam zu sehen dass infektionen
zugelassen werden für die
bevölkerungsgruppen die nicht gefährdet
sind für schwerer verläufe bei das
schützt uns letztendlich vor sozialen
einer großen welle wir müssen
herdenimmunität aufbauen das heißt wir
müssen infektionen zu lassen in dem maße
wie unser gesundheitssystem das eben
verkraften kann das wird dann passieren
in den nächsten wochen
wenn alles so bleibt wie es momentan
aussieht und dann reden wir sicherlich
nicht über eine allgemeine masken
pflicht in deutschland das wäre
vollkommen okay jetzt wird's jetzt
wird's spannend
das ist tatsächlich relativ strittige
these da gibt es auch andere die sagen
wir dürfen nicht so viele anstecken wie
viele menschen sollten sich denn jetzt
anstecken können oder wenn sie wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe dass man
guckt das ist eine durchseuchung gibt
aber in maßen cent also tendieren sie
dazu
genau das muss natürlich sehr gut
überlegt sein da müssen die fachleute
die epidemiologen das ganz genau
berechnen was welchen effekt dann zeigt
aber lässt sich das alles neuland da ist
mal sehr vorsichtig vorgehen sicherlich
bei den kindergärten und schule den
anfang und dann schauen nach 14 tage wie
steigt die zahl der infektionen kann das
sozusagen mit einem bestimmten backup
auch auf den intensivstationen
abgefedert werden das ist letztendlich
die strategie und natürlich geht es auch
weiterhin darum die besonders hohe
korrelation die älteren die patient mit
vorkamen besonders gut zu schützen und
da brauchen wir genau diese masken ja
und die wird natürlich fehlen wenn jetzt
die leute massenhaft auch diese masken
kaufen die sie eigentlich gar nicht
benötigen wir keinen die keine gefahr
haben schwer zu erkranken
insofern sind wir gar nicht in dem
zustand jetzt eigentlich das zu
diskutieren mit den masken es gibt nicht
genügend wir brauchen sind die
krankenhäuser die altenpflegeheime und
insofern hat sich diese diskussion mit
den masken zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
erledigt die notwendigkeit besteht nicht
das heißt fragt entschuldigung fragen
wie von allein auf youtube die zum
beispiel wissen wollte sie hat sich
selber eine stoffmaske genäht mit ihrer
mutter und des sketches skeptisch ob das
was bringt da würden sie ganz klar sagen
nein
und es gab ja auch diese bilder von
armin laschet die habe ich das grabmal
auf meinem rechner gelegt vielleicht
schalten wir mal kurz drauf haben in nrw
ministerpräsident von der cdu der eine
maske trägt die aber nur seinen mund
bedeckt
das ist ja dann im endeffekt genau das
wovor virologen und auch ärzte immer
wieder waren das die dann auch falsch
angelegt und falsch benutzt werden
genau neben dem nicht natürlich fahren
den 100
henning schutz auch für andere kann sie
natürlich falsch benutzt werden sie
müssen auch oft ausgewechselt werden
also viele viele faktoren die dort eine
rolle spielen nochmal wenn es um masken
kaufen geht denke ich ist es keine gute
lösung wenn jetzt ein halt selbst wer
sich entschließt diese masken zu basteln
und zu verwenden ist das ja eine
privatsache die kann jeder für sich
selbst entscheiden nicht als er musste
sich aber darüber im klaren sein es ist
natürlich kein schutz für sich selber
und der schutz auch für andere ist
begrenzt und gerade wenn man in die
anderen sachen berücksichtigt abstand
halten die hygienemaßnahmen ist schon
sehr sehr viel getan
ich habe jetzt hier einen entsetzten
kommentar von einer userin von der ich
tatsächlich zufällig weiß dass die
mehrfach schwer krank ist und ganz viel
wert auf hygiene legt 7 halt was reden
sie denn da ist es jetzt so dass man mit
so wenn man mit solchen risiko gruppen
in kontakt ist dann sollte man doch auf
jeden fall irgendwie schauen dass man
solche masken benutzt oder ist es dann
auch eher weniger andere hände waschen
abstand halten geht es nach lage sagt
bei den risikogruppen ist das ganz
wichtig dass da das material vorhanden
ist es ging jetzt hier und die
allgemeine massen nützlich für die
gesamte bevölkerung die einfach raus in
den park gehen das ist nicht sinnvoll
gut es ist ganz wichtig dass die wohl
gerade population mit vorerkrankungen
die älteren dass die optimal geschützt
sind dort brauchen wir die
mundschutzmasken als auch die
atemschutzmasken wenn jemand erkrankt
ist um dadurch auch das pflegepersonal
zu schützen
also das bitte noch mal ganz klar
trennen voneinander okay dann haben wir
das jetzt noch mal geklärt damit alle
beruhigt sind und nichts falsches tun
wenn wir noch mal ganz kurz zu den
weiteren maßnahmen kommen erreichen uns
ganz viele fragen natürlich von matthias
schwabe auf youtube wenn alles gut läuft
es eine aufhebung der maßnahme nach
ostern realistisch andere wollen wissen
wann risikogruppen wieder raus dürfen
mal die schwarz auf instagram hat das
zum beispiel gefragt
können sie da irgend eine prognose
abgeben oder ist das tatsächlich
kaffeesatzleserei ja das ist
kaffeesatzleserei da kann niemand eine
prognose abgeben wir müssen bitte jetzt
noch die tage abwarten ich hoffe die
situation bleibt so wie sie momentan ist
und dann kann man nach ostern
entscheiden welche maßnahmen gelockert
werden das wäre natürlich nicht alle auf
einmal sein
man muss das schrittweise vorgehen und
schauen wie sich dann wieder diese
aktionen 14 tage zeigt in 14 tagen zeigt
ich hoffe sie wird stabil bleiben unser
gesundheitssystem ist stark genug die
mehrzahl infektion denn abzufedern
und dann können wir schritt für schritt
weitere maßnahmen eben auch locker
sie müssen leider ins team gleich
beenden weil sie gleich ins nächste
gespräch wir müssten sie sind sehr
gefragt eine frage hätte ich aber gerne
noch gestellt nämlich von traditionell
auch auf instagram es gibt ja diese
maßnahmen von auf- und abschwellenden
kurven das heißt man versucht
infizierung herbeizuführen in maßen und
dann wieder zurück zu nehmen damit die
krankenhäuser quasi immer nur in
abständen verlaufen ist das eine
maßnahme die tatsächlich realistisch
durchsetzbar ist
na ja ich würde mal sagen so in sehr
steilen kurvenverlauf dass wir mehrere
kurven haben
das wäre nicht günstig am besten wir das
natürlich ein gleichbleibendes niveau zu
halten aber das ist eben sehr sehr
schwer planbar und vorhersagbar insofern
wird es natürlich schon zu diesen kurven
kommen aber ideal wäre es natürlich wenn
wir einen niveau ein gleichbleibendes
niveau finden was sozusagen durch das
gesundheitssystem aufgefangen werden
kann und wo wir eben auch wieder
freiräume schaffen für die wirtschaft
und für das tägliche zusammenleben damit
dass sozusagen wieder vorwärts geht war
ganz klar diese maßnahmen die es sehr
strikt sind haben auch medizinische
nebenwirkungen und das dürfen wir nicht
aus den augen verlieren darum ist es
hier auch richtig dass immer mit
augenmaß vorgegangen wird
ja und das ist bisher eigentlich gut
gelungen in deutschland dann danke ich
ihnen erst mal für ihre zeit jetzt ich
bin sicher wir werden uns noch öfter
unterhalten müssen über die
verschiedenen fragestellungen
vielen dank erstmal professor schmidt
chanasit nach hamburg und vielen dank
für die fragen das tut mir leid dass wir
nicht alle beantworten konnten ich
möchte nur eine sache noch loswerden
hier werden immer wieder zahlen
angezweifelt die offiziellen zahlen des
robert koch- institut hier wird dazu
aufgerufen sich bei anderen
informationsquellen zu informieren das
ist eine sache da muss ich natürlich
euch dringend vor rahmen weil es
kursieren gerade sehr viele gerüchte
sehr viele verschwörungstheorien
teilweise auch sehr viele videos in
denen behauptet wird dass wir alles
überhaupt nicht so schlimm das wäre nur
eine grippe und man sollte den ganzen
offiziellen informationen nicht glauben
weil die ein ganz anderes ziel hätten
und da müssen wir leider euch sagen das
ist alles nicht so es wäre schön wenn es
tatsächlich so wäre weil dann müssten
wir als journalisten relativ schneller
verwarnen und sagen wir können die
maßnahmen wieder runterfahren aber
tatsächlich ist das nicht so das
robert-koch-institut bemüht sich alle
theologen bemühen sich und auch da wenn
ihr quellen habt die euch merkwürdig
vorkommen fragt lieber noch mal jemanden
und nicht jeder der ein medizinischen
titel trägt ist tatsächlich auch in der
lage über viren verlässlich auskunft zu
geben deswegen reden wir ausschließlich
mit virologen darüber in diesem sinne
danke ich euch erstmal für eure
aufmerksamkeit und zeit bis zum nächsten
stream und tschüss
[Musik]